- Il règne chez les Kehl
La plus jeune, Johanna,a 15 ans,
est enseignante. Jonathan,
lui, poursuit ses études
universitaires et eeeee
lui aussi vers l'enseignement.
Il n'avait pas de frère.esesesee
kilomètres de Bad Hersfeld,
leur petite ville d'Allemagne,
un Canadien a désormais du sang
génétique que le sien.
Jonathan lui a fait don
Il l'appelle son jumeau
génétique, même si cet homme
a plus que deux fois son âge.
fascinant que quelqu'un accepte
de donner àt t t t t t inconnu.
Et, Je dis tout le temps que
ça nous réconforte, ça
réconcilie avec la nature
humaine.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est la docteure
Sylvie Lachance, du programme de
Rosemont, à Montréal, qui a
choisi le profil de Jonathan,
dans la banque allemande de
donneursitititititititititititie
avec celui de son patient.
- On va souvent faire appel
à des donneurs quand on est
canadiens, des donneurs
américains, souvent des donneurs
européens, et chez les donneurs
dedededededededededededededededs
allemande, elle est formidable
pour la profonde
- Au moment de la greffe, le
plus grand secret est maintenu.
sur l'identité du receveur
et vice versa, mise à
pour Jonathan, un indice.
Puisqu'il a fallu prélever
une grande quantité de cellules
sont dit que le patient devait
être costaud.
(On cogne à la porte.)
- Entrez!tetetetetetetetetetete.
- Bonjour Monsieur Leblanc.
Comment allez-vous?
- Ça va bien, ça va bien.
- Ouhehehehehehehehehehehehehehc
Leblanc, est plutôt grand.
Mais à l'époque, en 2019, il ne
se sentait pas fort du tout.
Souffrant de lymphome non
hodgkinien, un cancer
il craignait le pire.ANANANANAN,
Aff. intergouv., Infra et Coll.
- Moi, j'avais peur quand
je suis allé dans la salle de
bahahahahahahahahahahahahahahah,
je me voyais dans le miroir,
j'avais des yeux complètement
jaunes. Mais les médecins, là,
semaines. Si on ne peut pas
trouver les recettes de ch
qui allaient mettre la malututut
aller vers une greffe."
- Oui, il l'a échappé belle
chimiothérapie qui a été
appliquée. I
excessivement malade. On peut
dire que sa vie était en dangere
d'opportunité pendant laquelle
la maladie a répondu.
- Pendant ce temps,
en Allemagne, Jo
être prêt pour le prélèvement.
Pendant quelques jours, il a dû
stimule la quantité des cellules
souches
lui qui avait peur
des aiguilles.
De quoi rendre sa mère un
Mais l'engagement de son filsin
question. Une vie était en jeu.
étaient destinées ses cellules
souches, Jonat
déjà en partie responsable
du receveur.
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a e
l'identité du donneur.
- C'est arrivé sur un courriel
il y avait son adresse.
Puis, qu'est-c d d d d d d d d .
Il est né en 2000.
le clan qui était soucieux.
Qui était ce mystérieux
receveur? Mais surtout, était-il
Lorsque la bonne nouvelle est
arrivée, les soeurs étaient
plus excitées que leur frère.
La mnininininininininininininin.
Il avait peine à croire qu'il
souches à un ministre canadien.
Ses grands-p
la nouvelle.
Pour lui, s'inscrire dans
le registre de donneurs avai
Son école avait organiséouououor
les inscriptions des
Il a fait comme presque tous
ses camarades. Il a donné
un échantillon de son ADN.
- Toutes les cellules sont
arrivées.ioioioioioioioioioioios
à travers le monde. E
les avancées dans les techniques
de greffe, il est plus facile
donneur. Docteure Lachance croit
tout de même
pourrait s'inspirer de
l'Allemagne et sensibiliser
au don de cellules souches.
ssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssss
qui ne sont post-mortem, maisi s
souches. Donc, c'est un don
quvavavavavavavavavavavavavavav.
- Ça, c'est la soeur qui joue
au piano.
- Oui.ururururururururururururu?
Les parents ont l'air jeun
- Pour le donneur comme pour
le receveur, ce don est toutmmmé
pour toujours. Lui a fait de
coeur un geste extraordinaire
qui m'a donné une deuxième vie.
- Domini
savoir sur son donneur.
- Ah oui, ça, c'est cool.
un chien.
rencontrés en personne,
ils ont déjà fait connaissance
- Hey, Jonathan.
- Hello.
- How ar a a a a a a a a a a a e
you?- - - - - - - - - - - - - -,
malgré la trentaine d'années
tititititititititititititititit,
sont liés pour la vi